Church to what's happened uh opening up
with a bomb out of respect for sober
October reading some podcast Ville the
church what's happened now is you buy
kettle bell kitchen yeah
their mission is to change people's
lives to make making healthy food more
accessible isn't eating healthy is on
everybody's mind right now correct what
when and how much eat it's hard to know
where to start with kettle bell kitchen
calm you listen and helps you stay on
your diet by taking out the hassle of
shopping and cooking these meals come
right to you twice per week whatever
works for you vegetarian keto whole
dirty poleo they got it listen they sent
me a beautiful kid it had the grass-fed
steak
the bison beef sliders tremendous sure
and I don't even like bison beef how's
that being so what the hell are you
waiting for
feed the champion inside here with
kettle bell kitchen go to tell about
kitchen right now and then to coat
Church CH you are CH for twenty-five
dollars off each of your first two
orders to the new customers that's
twenty five hours for the first two
orders at ten about kitchen comm press
in church the church is also brought to
you by hymns listen for hymns calm is a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness remember listen when
age comes wisdom
but getting older can also be a downer
in a specific area
forty percent of men by the age of forty
struggle from not being able to get and
maintain an erection that's how many a
minute okay now why do guys turn to weed
solutions or do nothing when they could
turn to medicine and science for hems
calm has the answer with well-known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you combat Edie
you see the results where other
treatments fall short
try James calm
today try hymns today by starting out
with a free online visit go to for hymns
calm slash Church you can grab a pen for
hymns F for hims dot-com slash Church
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
give you a first resupport listen this
would cost hundreds if you went to a
doctor's office or a pharmacist right
now just go to forums comm slash church
listen I'm not gonna tell you again
it's [__] Wednesday right but
tomorrow it starts all over again
everybody wants to make money everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die I got the answer my bookie calm
my bookie dot AG football season is upon
us right you like making money you like
betting sports they got basketball
football Mme too [__] praying mantises
fighting in Jersey they got everything
if you're trying to bet the NFL baseball
and let's they got better incentives and
more lines than any other [__] sports
book they just revamped their site it
looks [__] tremendous go take a look
already if you have it I'm what I'm
going to do is this I'm gonna double
your first deposit today right now use
promo code Church CH you are CH and get
100% bonus on your initial deposit up to
$1,000 is better than you nobody visit
my bookie done AG today
that's my bookie my be oh okay i e dot
AG and don't forget to use promo code
Church when creating your account to
claim this bonus listen you play your
when you get paid cut this [__] go to my
bookie dot AG kick this [__]
melee alright what's happening here Greg
Fitzsimmons Joey Diaz I gotta tell you
man you're the real deal just just
hanging out with you for 10 minutes
before the show nothing makes me happier
you don't you just don't [__] real guy
you don't get no there's no [__] about
sober October making me laugh about
[__] Ari I just gonna hit don't bond
it yeah it's a beautiful thing to be
alive exchange degrees outside we've got
our
yep we got harms we got a house right no
Edie no erectile dysfunction
fall down a flight of stairs whoa what's
that your deck uh I'm getting to the
point now where you get it there
and once you bang out one then you're
done yeah like done it used to be like
the one that would stay half an
attention yeah and you go back in there
for the second stab and that last little
longer I really see stars yeah that got
cut out now I get it I got a 24 hour
shot clock on mine now it resets 24
hours it's and the worst is I go to my
office I got an office like this about
the same size just [__] it all business
and little couch and you know watching
Japanese hidden-camera massage boring
lesbians and I work one out and I come
home that night and the wife throws a
move on me after the kids go to bed and
I gotta look a right in the eye and go
too late sweetie too late that one's
gone no I usually don't bang one out of
the daytime on a late-night type of dude
really yeah I don't know why I'm not a
date time bang Hirata
I like late night when I got nothing to
do at night he bored he might as well
bang one out I go take a pee and I'll
bang one out standing up no [__] yeah
I'm old school
yeah you've landed all in the water and
it's it all over the place yeah no I
landed right in the toilet then I closed
and it's a little space see monkey
member in the 70 yeah I'll come on that
toilet lid down I go away I come back
two days later I got like a half a
kidney yeah there's like a handle to fly
out of in there telling me help me help
me down the toilet yeah I heard of
[__] horses I got a back path room
that gets those [__] flies yeah okay
I mean they're slow they get bigger I
love what happens I open up the door and
I take a [__] and while I'm taking a
[__] you know yeah I love taking this
[__] with the back door open
yeah I heard when we went through this
house and I saw the layout nobody comes
to that
you have to walk through too many mazes
so it's my bad I got a couple
kettlebells on the law I got some club
weights and [__] I got to punch him bad
two gloves in there I got my bong in
there I got that like wall watching the
back door my Santa read his stuff and I
got this [__] and it's perfect and I
opened the back door and the Sun comes
in it's 6:00 in the morning after my
first cup of coffee and as I'm [__]
smoking bong hits this [__] flying out
of my ass when you go up what's better
than coughing another bomb there's
nothing better no it comes right out
and for some reason lately as you get
old you get those extended pieces of
[__] well heck the ones that aren't long
no more they they're like 6 inches but
the middle has like a four inch gap yeah
the mushroom track so you're a stretches
out for a minute yeah it's like [__]
you guys are both saying yes like what
are you talking about as you get older
your body change okay you young guys so
you [__] change so they last Monday and
I gotta be honest yeah I'm on that
Murray I I do not do pain pills but I
had an Altoid can people give me on the
road people give me a little different
pills I put in my little output vicodins
hydrocodone what everything about do you
know what each one is not really you
know I have an idea but not really so
some nights you know so when we had the
last night before so about October we
came in here we had a like Cisco lien
trees and I hate them let me tell you
how much I don't need pain pills they
clog me up all week oh yeah
that's the problem they destructed me
all week coffee I just feel this [__] in
my stomach
yeah I finally said [__] this yeah the
morning I ran over the Pete's the
Mexican place up there they got a fruit
salad whatever you eat there at the end
they give you a fruit cup with the
Mexican cream on top
it makes you [__] the dick hard just
eat it yeah give you a couple
blueberries raspberries and strawberries
and melon the green melon right it's
tremendous I just went up then said give
me a fruit thing with no cream on it
give me half the cream I hate the whole
[__] thing and Friday night I was on
to Rome like I said they were coming out
in chunks yeah you could hear it it's
like people throw the sheetrock yeah and
your [__] is distended three times I
went in then it was like ten minutes of
my life
flushing I gotta get up and [__] get
the pogo stick and push it down whatever
the [__] you call that loading the
cannon yeah the [__] I got the big
extended one for gorillas yeah the ones
they use in the gorilla cage and the
Bronx Zoo I'm pushing down on this
[__] but for some reason my
antenna I had tracked these flies and
they go against the bathroom window and
they kind of get [__] yeah right so
after a few days they just come into my
lair and I got a little weed container a
glass container that's empty we'd put
them in there I take one of their wings
off to [__] them up a little bit and I
put little holes and I feed him weed I
just give them weed and for three or
four days they're just eating weed they
don't know and I just put more flies in
there got about eight of them in there
right now never you let him out no no
they're in there I'm like I say I might
do an animal like that that collected
the bugs and put them up chubby chicks
[__] yeah and then they would drop them
off in the weeds off the 170 what's them
brother put the cream on the skin that
dude's jaw gentle ocean in the bucket
drop the lotion in the bucket no no bugs
going in the [__] that was a moth that
was a more oh god I don't know it but
watching their mouths or something yeah
that's how they found them around the
Mort in the mountain right
tastes figured up in the morgue odd sent
from some other country yeah no I take
those vicodin I got a I got shoulder
surgery it's probably going back five
years
I got shoulder surgery just from
repeated throwing [__] my entire life
just the right the right shoulder needed
to be rebuilt and they gave me I had the
surgeon
write me vicodin I had the general
practitioner write me hydrocodone I had
somebody in physical therapy write me
somebody I was filling every everyone
for [__] nine months these guys kept
refilling it and then I go into people's
medicine cabinets if I
came to your house for dinner I'd excuse
myself to go to the bathroom and I would
rifle through your [__] and I would take
your hydrocodone if there's anybody out
there friends family that have had me
over in the last five years and you
think you got a little hydrocodone left
when you get a backache you're gonna
have to refill that that's gone thank
you for the honesty yeah that's what I
put my [__] the bathroom I go to open
houses I got my medication in the
weirdest places yeah like my blood
pressure medications your kitchen next
to refrigerator some reminded to take it
yeah and all my amendment met them at
the little Dew pills those are hidden
because I don't want mercy to find them
now you got to get a saint
I don't first of all I don't have them
to pull up in my like some people take
them and they put them in their medicine
cab yeah I don't have no anxiety should
the doctor gives me yeah I don't put it
in there I don't even take it on the
road I wash more those anxiety pills
away are you telling me you put him in
your pocket because we watch the store
good I take yeah you know so but it was
interesting before the park guests
thought I would become at the Friars
Club oh right what are the requirements
well back in the day the requirements
were that you have to be a man I don't
know what the I don't think there was
ever a race restriction there's a lot of
private clubs in New York that had race
restrictions you know you had the the
Union Club and the Players Club there
was a whole like circuit of private
clubs are mostly in like old beautiful
brownstones like five-story brownstones
and the Friars Club was founded as a
club for entertainers it was for
comedians borscht belt guys that were on
the road Broadway actors songwriters
entertainment attorneys agents and they
would they all joined this club and they
would just hang out and they had a Joey
Lewis bar you came in on the left and it
was one of these old-time New York bar
is with the [__] red padded rubber on
the edge of the bar and then some deep
black booths in the back and they serve
you the [__] peanuts that everybody's
pissy hands when rifling through all day
but you eat them anyway and guys just
come in there
after work have a couple drinks and then
during the day guys that come in for
lunch the dining room was [__]
beautiful
it was the Frank Sinatra dining room and
you get the Dover sole and they they
take the bones out right at the table
they come over and they filet it for you
right at the table and just put it on
your account nobody you don't bring
money to the Friars Club
everything is just they know your number
they throw it down then you go upstairs
and they got a card room guys play cards
all day betting all [__] like these do
they're working at night they're comics
so they have their lunch they play cards
and an upstairs they get a steam room
that's the best steam room in the city
and you walk in you get your little
locker and then they give you a robe and
you walk into the steam room guy comes
in he's got a towel and then he's got a
washcloth that they stay this got ice
cubes on it and he hands you that the
glass of water and then when you get out
you walk into the shower you take a
shower
big [__] big shower with the the
power nozzle that blows that [__] it's
like a civil rights riot in the 60s
you're getting blasted against the
German Shepherds are barking underneath
of the stall and then you come out and
this Polish guy takes a towel not making
this up and he [__] Pat's you dry
your whole body you just stand there
with your arms out this guy Pat's you
dry everything but your dick and then he
wrapped a towel around your waist hands
you another glass of water and then you
go back and you go sit and you put the
robe on and they got these these lazy
boys sitting outside by the gym
big-screen TV Variety magazine Hollywood
Reporter and you sit down and you
[__] watch a little MSNBC read
variety put a towel on your head take a
nap and then you go out to your show
that night do you have to let the guy
draw you off why wouldn't you I don't
know that's it was great feeling how
long have you been a member of this wall
I joined in 93 one of the requirements I
mean you gotta have somebody recommend
you in second you and then they review
you and then you come in and mmm they
have a little ceremony but they
where you in and read to the rules and
all that stuff so I joined my father was
a friar my whole life I watched I
watched the OJ chase and the Friars Club
I watched you know the 86 Mets win the
World Series in that Friars Club they
had a they have a TV viewing room that's
fantastic you know and the waiters are
everywhere and [__] black jackets and
bowties getting you drinks and and then
my I sponsored this woman Sarah Fearon
funny comedic actress kind of quirky and
I I submitted her she got accepted she
goes the ceremony and she brings her
friend Erin and I'm there and I talked
to Erin she's with a guy but I talked
her for like 20 minutes and then after
the ceremony I said to Sarah Fearon I
said I'm gonna marry your friend someday
and three years later I started dating
Erin took her to the Friars Club
proposed in a Milton Berle room I
proposed to her she said yes the rest is
history it's a beautiful story yeah not
gonna ask you a question yeah you're a
pretty smart guy we love each other we
really do I know you can say right now
why the [__] don't I want to go back I
got a call last night in Josh wolf well
let's start the story straight you know
day I'm watching TV we come back we'll
show you the first know Hollywood
marijuana restaurant a cafe and they
flash to it they show a bunch of white
kids online and vapor and they show
people inside Han smoking a blunt and
they got high-powered fans and right
there the food's all got pot in it I
don't know yeah right then I knew like
you would never see me close to that
yeah I knew at that decision last night
I said I was talking with Josh
have you gone to it yeah that's great
and he goes you should go and I go Josh
I won't go I know you you do know that I
would never step foot in that [__]
place you know I've been smoking dope
since I was 12 I got nothing to prove to
no black everyone a little restaurant
yeah and that's all anyone's talking
about a smoking dope every night it's
it's but no back to the why do I feel
this way I mean you're a smart guy like
I sit at home at nights like I scheduled
myself because I know I'm at an age I
can't go out two nights in a row at the
Comedy Store it's too much exciting for
me yeah so now after is they gotta take
a nap so I'd rather go to the store
Tuesday and Thursday and space it out
belong sitting at home Wednesday it's
eight o'clock my daughter's going to bed
at 8:30 and my wife doesn't give a
Frenchman's [__] what I do and I got 20
options and I don't want to do any of
them it's so weird not to offend you you
know I dearly love you I've seen like
pictures in the Friars Club and how they
act and Billy Crystal I would stab
myself in the eye after five minutes and
then I don't want another like [__] yeah
you know it's like I still remember
wanting to go to Montreal so bad and
saving up the money and I talked Slayton
to put me on during the dirty show I
took a flight to Detroit when I checked
in to the hotel room Detroit cuz I was
gonna go to Montreal in the morning I
was like who the [__] am i T though that
didn't invite me I'm not a part of those
people and even if I know that I don't
want to be there like oh my god you have
such a great time at the bar yeah it's
the same jerk Louis I could see on
Tuesday at the Comedy Store right I just
see them now getting drunk in there in
there and vive it I don't wanna I don't
know what it is about me like I do not
want to go there well you're an outsider
that's your that your identity is you
did it your way and maybe you weren't
embraced by the mainstream you were
given the same kind of breaks that
somebody else might have gotten and I
don't know why I mean some
people could say it's uh maybe because
people are afraid you you're you know
you're aggressive on stage you say [__]
nobody else says it's not politically
correct it could be racists
you know you're not you're not white and
you know you're I'm not you're a felon
do it do it you're an out isn't the
security that I have or is it a
character that I've created for me it
feels like like I've always felt this
way I remember the night you came down
and this this might this might have felt
like that environment to you as I was
doing I do a benefit show every year for
the best buddies we're doing at the
improv
and it was like for whatever reason I
ended up booking I usually booked it
because I'm I'm at somebody's house and
they got people over and I think I got a
book this [__] thing except for you
who I just call for any time I do a
benefit I call you straight out of the
gate and I was there so it was Zach
Galifianakis and it was Sarah Silverman
and I think might have been Brian post
saying so it was kind of like I think it
might have represented like that kind of
Largo world in that alternative comedy
world that maybe you never felt a part
of and I remember seeing you you didn't
come in the room you were standing in
the back you don't want to come until
you went on and I think you were feeling
like a little bit trepidatious you know
and I hadn't seen you like that before
and he went onstage and you [__]
ripped it apart and you were doing the
bit about the chick pissin in your face
and you just didn't give a [__] and I'm
sitting with them in the corner and I'm
curious to see what their reaction is
gonna be to you you know cuz this is not
Largo this is not you know pro-feminist
what you know with their use and if
their [__] jaws were slacked they were
like what-what just blew on stage what
[__] storm just settle over the
microphone of the improv now and they
they [__] loved it they were like this
is unbelievable and I remember you
walking out and and I knew that I don't
know that you saw them or how they
reacted but I think you felt really good
that you just did what you do and that
whatever anxiety you were feeling before
that didn't come onstage with you it
pure Joey Diaz on that stage well I
always have anxiety yeah you know once I
walked into the battle zone
yeah The Comedy Store ding xiety goes up
150% right it's like when Michael you
know one of the greatest things about
The Godfather is what whatever whoever
the director was or whatever the idea he
got when Michael goes into the bathroom
before he shoots so I get the gun yeah
and the bran the Train that train if I
know Greg Fitzsimmons is sitting in this
office and I gotta put a hit on Greg
Fitzsimmons I'll have to do it myself at
9 o'clock at night well he's doing a
podcast lately as I walk up those stairs
your adrenaline goes so high as I've
been in that situation before I rob
somebody or rob jewelry when anytime I
did anything that was that creepy like
you robbed the house or robbing a drug
dealer you go deaf you hear us like
that's all I would hear like your heart
is telling so much there's so much
adrenaline ball into your body that
that's what you hear you kind of hear a
simulation of what Michael heard on that
train the other I went to the store my
wife made chicken college for lunch she
went to church she made chicken college
when she came back I like to chicken
collars don't wait for eight - chicken
college because what he wanted for
dinner she gave me the menu for dinner I
was like you know what don't worry about
how I go to store anyway I'll stop at
Joe's beats and get better I just got a
slice I got had 14 points left so I get
to the Comedy Store the other night some
dear kid I've known for 20 years was
talking to me
I really couldn't hear even with the
hearing aids on I couldn't hear him at
the Biennale I didn't want to hear just
nothing to talk about when I walked in
there was two boxes and Joe's pizza
on the piano in the main room I didn't
eat in the green room to the green room
yeah I didn't touch right you know and I
remember going onstage and get it over
with
no when I came back I could hear the kid
mm-hmm I could have a conversation right
why are you talking to me right I'm
about to go to war
yeah what are you talking about
anyhow I can hear he sounded like
Charlie Bern well my lovely and he kept
talking until he finally got at that
this guy doesn't want to be bothered or
he's not even hearing yes like I'm going
up in the main room I don't time for
just more talk right I don't give a [__]
about whatever the [__] where we met did
a guest spot on your show in st. Louis
four years ago and you're supposed to
remember
I got a jog my memory about something
it's like if I remembered you it means
you were memorable if I don't remember
you
let's not rehash something that wasn't
that important in the first place that's
why I hate doing two shows because I
want to talk to the people after the
first show the crowd but if you have a
second show you really can yeah that's
an hour quit all said it's [__]
jeopardy right you know it's Wesley do
you remember we send episode 274 the
Rogan podcast why did you say this Hans
Greg Fitzsimmons this podcast just take
the picture - shut your [__] what the
[__] I just said on stage and you want
to know what's with the [__]
questions
take the [__] big try it and then
they get the camera out and it's the the
the [__] lock is on the girlfriend's
trying to open it yes yes I know the
code yeah eight minutes yeah with your
stupid [__] question which I have no
idea what you're saying
we're in a room with 300 people on a
line waiting to take pictures I got no
[__] idea what you said come over
here let me give you a compliment take a
picture let's get the [__] out of here
Yeah right and then they come back and
they tell you stories I can't [__]
hear you even with the [__] earpiece
I can't [__] hear there's three other
people in the [__] room so before I
go on like I really like the car
long after my loom that Flitz the buckle
I made a decision I'm only gonna Comedy
Store and I have a bit like tonight I
love my friends but you know what leave
me the [__] alone on Tuesday you don't
want to come to the store or Tuesday
night it's chaos it's chaos it's two
sold-out shows in the main room one of
the original rule is three sold-out
shows in the belly that's a total of
1,200 people in that building
not to mention 100 comics lurking to
suck on blood or they were the [__] they
do down there and the staff and the
waitresses you know you want to come
down and I [__] Tuesday night and
talked I wanted to bring you the script
you know what yes they my god I worked
right you know not like about Tuesday
night well I told you that night when I
called you we saw magic fender yes I go
in that I get two orders I [__] get
high I think an animal sometimes and I
want to sit in the original and monster
three comics before me and I want to
learn and I don't want to be bothered
guess what I'm gonna get the [__] out of
here we just stupid [__] voices yeah
I'm watching how he won't get the [__]
out if i watch Ally one is okay yeah you
know I like when I see you you sit next
to me we hug each other and we both
watch and laugh all right
right there's people like um I never
forget one night I'm sitting there
minding my own business and somebody
bent over and whispered in my ear are
you taking the Charlotte with you and I
just gave him a look killer gave that
white guy at the diner and heat I had to
go down and vow come and look at them
like what the [__] are you talkin about
like back iceladyga yeah yeah I've seen
this guy he's a sweet out of a guy right
sweetheart of a guy oh and here's what I
get there's this female comic at the
store and I'm outside and somebody goes
oh you know so-and-so and I look at her
I go I don't think I don't think we've
met I'm Greg and she goes doesn't shake
my hand yeah we met before we met before
and I've been and I've been a comic here
for such and such amount of time
and I go sorry about that I just you
know I don't have a great memory I have
[__] terrible memory
I have no facial recognition whatsoever
and forget names so that becomes her
thing now every time I see her she does
this oh yeah you don't remember you do
you remember me this time it's like hey
look sweetie you know I I do my best
just because some people have
photographic memories you got a guy like
Patton Oswalt that guy can remember the
[__] third track on a you know on a
[__] Aerosmith album that flopped in
the 80s and you knows every word to it
he can name every person that was on a
show I don't have that memory I don't
remember [__] so you're gonna hold it
against me it's not that I don't like
you you're perfectly fine I watched her
actually did I remember the first time I
met her no [__] let it go I have a
phenomenal long-term that really words
speeches but this times I'm reading a
book like a crime book or something and
they describe a conversation I always
think about that conversation how do you
[__] remember something that was said
in the room thirty years ago right guess
what I still remember specific
conversations I had with people lines
from movies oh yeah lines from movies
how great ask me what I did yesterday or
the day before now hmm at this age I'm
starting to forget yeah when you go to
this you know when you go on the road
you see some waitresses at some clubs
they're there every eighteen months you
know when you go to the [__] funny
ball in Columbus to manage it with the
glasses she's great
she's been there for 30 something yes
you know so you read Marcy Marcy the the
cooked in Columbus the big black drills
right right you know you just have
become and but you have you ever gone to
an improv and a waiter for the last four
years you've gone to Miami and he works
in Miami but all of a sudden he
transfers to the University of Tempe and
you do Tempe
you see him he throws your whole [__]
week off yeah I know this [__]
yeah I should be in Miami where's the
rest of the I mean that's the worst
right you know we're at an age now where
I try my hardest I tried my hardest
you know what there's people I give hugs
to and talk to I don't know their names
I could count they store yeah
there's two guys in particularly that I
got confused all the time
I just don't know their name foggy
memoir yeah I can say that all [__]
day make him follow me well I'm on stage
you're getting a lonesome cannot bring
yeah yeah yeah it's the most embargo
funny Mahwah funny mom wah bring me up
on stage yeah why go Jeff who's up next
for a memoir I've [__] my insides
cracked yeah cuz I know where the worst
is they just say Fahim you don't tell
you the last name and then sometimes you
spaced on the last yeah I got I brought
you up I said an intro about you yeah as
I was doing the intro I was I almost
forgot your name I did the Tara quiet
like my best open mic buddy first time I
did the belly room I forgot his name as
I was bringing him up I thought it was
just me I'm glad dude I used to be I
used to be at an agency and and I had I
had a few different agents you know they
cover you when one person does TV one
person for your writing and another
person books you stand up so you got
three different agents at one agency and
the woman that booked my acting which
was not a lot because I've never done a
lot of acting but she was my acting age
and I was trying to do more you know
sitcom auditions and stuff and she's
black and I'm walking down the hallway
with my stand-up agent and I see her and
I go hey Robin which is the assistant I
thought it was the assistant I go hey
Robin she's the assistants name no it
was the agent and she goes no I'm the
other black woman in the office your
agent and I was like all right and then
I walked down the hall I said to my
standup beige and I go I think I have to
leave the agency and I did I
which agencies because she the look in
her eyes she was so [__] she was so
pissed off and I knew there was no
recovery from it I was kind of halfway
out the door anyway I use it as an
excuse but it was awkward yeah why can't
we were nametag
yeah I love that I'm sure I've been
terrible at names that was my when I was
a kid I worked at movie theaters in CVS
and you had name tags and then I went to
restaurants no name tags I worked it
like it's it's all there's so many
people it's not even just because you
guys managed to being a teacher when you
got home ugh you know when you got five
different classes a day coming in 30
kids and each it's a hundred and fifty
kids you got to learn fast cuz bye-bye
week three you got to know these [__]
kids names yeah you know there's like
parent-teacher conferences where these
parents all come in they want to know
how their kids doing
does he look like this is the one with
the clunky glasses or the acne I don't
know he seems to be doing all right
I don't know his name what a shame that
it's I I wouldn't get mad at somebody if
I still livin being an open mic and
emcee and [__] up a credit and I
comic just destroying me yeah and me
wanted to knock the [__] out but
he had every right to but you were
bombed anyway I wouldn't want them to
remember they get off stage wrong Maddie
you you [__] up why I was on NBC not
ABC yeah doesn't matter
you were playing a [__] you close with
a Tina Turner [__] song what are your
chances you're going to deep murky
waters of a cruise ship yeah those are
the people I mean I've never forgotten
yeah people yeah it also taught me how
to treat
comics mm-hmm like now my comics come up
to me mr. Diaz what he wants to say not
and their face is just drop do you say
nothing nothing
yeah really I studied you Oh Wikipedia I
know I read nothing and no way and then
afterward though I thank God oh there's
my time on stage I was all nervous no
boy I'm not here to make you nervous
but I remember working with comics that
came there purposely to make me nervous
and I think about them down that's why
they ended up zeros yeah because they
would abuse the feature in the [__] MC
you don't just say no bro yeah I know I
remember being at your level and having
a hard time remembering what I had to
say yeah you mean not anymore
nobody K it was a different generation
yeah they're already here there's
nothing in their seat they're gonna
watch you know I would I began I hope
you don't think I'm cynical people but
sometimes you have to be honest ease up
I started as a host just to let people
know I had a broker it was called a
broker in and it was tribbles Colorado
right so Tuesday was a boulder what a
great start to a week you're like I'm in
heaven
oh that Wednesday you got off and
Thursday you went to Craig Colorado and
on the call sheet for the week like they
would fax you the call sheets for the
week it would have Tuesday October 8th
Boulder they would have the address
contact Steve Harvey you're to get one
rule and one voucher for a free meal
pick up partial payment you'll pick up
65 hours and then for Craig it would go
Craig Colorado a Buck Hill Hotel the bar
is uh six miles from the the VFW hall
and it would go but it will be outlined
in red and it said this room is active
if bottles erupt or violence run by the
outside like I'll never forget that yeah
Thursday was gonna sin
sad for Friday was gonna Singh and
Saturday was Colorado Springs or some
but to what the point I'm getting to is
when you worked those triple runs and
again I'm not taking away from anybody
you work with a lot of frustrated and -
especially from here I worked with Doug
Stanhope as a feature that I worked with
maybe out of all those days 28 years ago
is this one I had then to this job my
first two years accompli still in the
business today I think there's maybe
three of them whether they were feature
acts my age there was three of and
they're still on that same circuit
that's three guys still around don't
know Stanhope is still around there's
one guy who was really hot because it
just wasn't for broken-down LA comics it
was also for comics on the upswing that
one of the workout material so we have a
lot of San Francisco guys that were
really good young comics but half the
month it was guys that they would walk
in and tell you how long you been doing
a kid six months quit now to get that
away you got a suck dick you gotta be
that's run by [__] yeah you know they
did but they were just and you could see
that they were just broken man yeah you
could even at that point I would cater
to him and be nice to him but I could
tell like that's where I met the guy
that replaced Chico in the man oh yeah
what do you think he felt like he went
on to become a great script writer huh
and he went on to teach acting class and
stuff like that but um when I met him he
was in that transition like he was a big
shot at the store you know he was on NBC
and now he was working on Tribble and
that's a car at home you know it's a
cold hard yeah yeah it's nice and you
look at you know it's just a weird age
my age right now how's your bore one
guys like it was I was working with a
lot of guys my yeah alright I was in LA
for 20 years and you gotta be a [__]
[__] yeah you got a sub dick
doing all the excuses [__] he sure
doesn't know what she's doing here
but Friedman made me audition eight
times to catch her and then you watch
their acting you're like are you [__]
kidding me
right Oh much more effort into where
they are who's holding them back what
they need to do to get there so she was
such a fool not any on their [__]
writing of their app it was such an
education yeah to meet the difference
I'm at a loss was very good well the
headline is that did the best job ever
Tony something he would proclaim to be
bill X's sponsor Tony visages okay he
came into a broken one in the in the
hour and took the [__] roof off I
bumped into me is laying my game a big
hug cuz he was very encouraging
he was Bill Hicks is alcohol sponsor
before my ex died he was around it was
an Easter I think he's still around
taxes Tony Vistage but besides that all
those comics disappeared yeah I remember
one that we had the two year anniversary
there was a big young comic from San
Francisco who was very witty and very
smart and when I moved to LA I bumped
into him he lived around the block from
me and his roommate was one of those
[__] knuckleheads that's still around
and he's working something he's gotta be
doing something dumb but he made a
mistake one that were at the store and I
had been at the store maybe three years
and in those days they used to have a
room in Orange County on Thursday nights
it was like an hour drive for me it was
a dinner theater do you remember that 20
years ago yeah I wasn't around how long
have you been in town 20 years about it
I didn't start at the store no no no no
about 20 years ago there was a room in
Orange County that was a dinner place oh
I thought it was one of them we did in
fact I did they were broke in about ten
years ago uh-huh
20 years ago was very [__] popular it
was Thursday night you gotta take the
405 north and
cut somewhere I don't remember it was
and you have yeah the four or five South
and then you gotta take off it wasn't
gonna have a [__] drive but it was
big time to get that game but the guy
have who booked a little and left the
other club egg beasts right whoever was
booking igby's mmm-hmm was now the
Booker down man and it was a place that
served you dinner it was a dinner
theater place but Thursday's they did
calmly and I mean everybody went down
there and I remember talking about a guy
at the store approached you a bit on
that so yeah so I'll forget that that
was the he was something way in charge
of booking that room that's why he would
go to the store on Friday night okay and
I'll never forget that one night he was
buying coke than chewy and so was I
while we were standing buying the coke
and chewie chewie said to me Joey that
was a hell of a spot tonight I'm gonna
thank you Joey and the kid made her and
Mark he goes I can follow him and about
a month later they booked me in that
room and he had a follow me yeah and it
was if you think I buried your hotel at
the store this was even worse this kid
was reaching when he got off stage he
threw chairs and complain he's still
around he's a hacker boom Taj I think
he's giving Hollywood Wars like if you
got a house where in a costume yeah
Hollywood to it yeah who's got a red
shirt you want to see what David Spade
lives at the [__] out of here suck my
dick I'll never forget him making that
stupid remark and it had to be 1999 yeah
like he just made the studio's I'd be
like the following right I'm just not a
regular at the store because Mitchie
like he he wanna be a regular he would
hang out down there and then give
regular [__] for being regular yeah yeah
there's no better feeling I remember
starting out with Rogen embossed and
there was there was a couple
that had that attitude towards us and
then that was that was all we did was it
made you stronger it made you go I'm
gonna [__] bury that guy so oh yeah
that was the greatest motivator to write
new [__] and work on your edge and work
on you know taking on an audience and
figuring out how to get inside them get
inside them and [__] explode them
from the inside you know to make contact
with them as a young comic all you're
doing is you're throwing [__] at them
you're just you're just like a it's a
slap fight you're not getting through
and then you start to develop your voice
and then you start to develop your
confidence and then you start to develop
your understanding of what a crowd is
and then suddenly you find your way in
you find your way to connect to them in
a way that they go oh this guy's in
charge they give over and you're the
Alpha and then the and then you start to
learn how to take that energy and
[__] explode that crowd and you
can'tyou that takes time it takes it
takes getting grounded on stage and not
being afraid to bomb so you can take
that risk
to really show them who you are and
connect and that's when you that's when
you blow a guy up what do you talk about
Rogan what year were you guys talking
about
89 started around 89 and you thirty
years I guess part of the clique at all
well Rogan was not at all he was in no
click at all and I was I played around
with like ket rising star had like David
Cross Louis CK's you need to Tullio
Janeane Garofalo some of the like
alternative people and some people that
with Jon Groff was like one of the
biggest showrunners and in LA now people
that Bryan Kylie people that are great
writers where we're hanging out a catch
rising star and it was there was a guy
there Robin Horton who was like curating
that vibe it was in Harvard Square so
you had all these Harvard kids coming in
and it was like David Cross did a thing
called cross comedy where it was do you
ever see mr. show that he did with Bob
Odenkirk it was the Foo is a predecessor
to mr. shell so his sketches mixed with
some stand-up and you know connecting
sketches to each other and sort of like
tangential ways it was interesting and I
used to do spots over there
we'd never be caught dead over there and
they they couldn't stand him
he couldn't stand them and he kind of
went out and he wasn't he wasn't
anywhere to make friends he was in it to
try to destroy and I was like him and I
were we're tight we were we were going
out on gigs together like Maine Vermont
New Hampshire Connecticut every night
never a [__] hotel you would drive
five hours up to Maine and they would
hand you some cash at the end of the
night get back in the car in a [__]
snowstorm and drive back to Boston so we
spent a lot of time in cars together and
and so we were tight and there was a
bunch of guys Tom Cotter was part of our
clique Tom Cotter and Al ducharme and
guy named Mike McDonald was down in
Florida now and we were like more of
like Kinison fans I think and Hicks fans
and I think those guys were more like
you know maybe Stephen Wright fans and
so but then you had the guys that were
the standards of Boston Don Gavin's
Steve Sweeney and Lenny Clark these guys
never left Boston but they could go you
put their name up in front of it there
were when we were starting out there
were six full-time clubs in downtown
Boston seven nights a week
hot crowds sold out it was [__] we
were the luckiest comics in the world we
were it's like Malcolm Gladwell talks
about you know in outliers how you know
whether whether or not the beat you know
the Beatles started out because they the
happenstance of being able to play in
Hamburg Germany where they had to play
for six hours a night and they did it
for weeks at a time four years at a time
and that's how they got they lied they
say you got to do 10,000 hours before
you get great at something and we were
in Boston playing in front of these
great crowds downtown then we go out on
the road and play tough saloons hecklers
you know working-class factory people in
Worcester Massachusetts that were broke
drinking [__] punch out of those
giant bowls with straws aku aku aku aku
I don't know you do that place
yeah no [__] I perform there oh [__] it
was hysterical because every time I did
that today with Tony V yeah the greatest
and it was an experience because he said
to me we play a game of big clock count
the deku would give you the punch balls
or bean balls
Scorpio delicious yeah brown rice
yeah the shrimp and lobster sauce yeah
yeah and then you go up and perform but
by the end of the night three people
would puke oh yeah and it would be egg
roll powder and the cabbage yeah mixed
with [__] pineapple juice and it
would stink - oh hell yeah
and the Chinese guy would have the I
don't have a little more rollers it was
like a box
oh yeah yeah Porto Ricans using this
[__] and like you can't [__] use them
if you have like confetti because
they'll pick up confetti these Chinese
guys are being pissed
I did the Accu action I loved it I loved
it because stanhope was from Worcester
yeah and I loved it because of the vibe
and yeah like when I first read about
the Boston the scene about like I never
liked Joe Rogan had nicked Lenny and
Lenny Clarke his brother Mike Clark yeah
I haven't listened to it yet yeah but I
loved all that like listening to all
those stories like he told me a story
that you guys used to play softball yeah
he still three days a week playing with
Janeane Garofalo yeah
didn't get into an argument with the
[__] the joke that the check bounced
off every no he's bouncing checks in Las
Vegas
ya know what he's back in Boston it
chased him out of Vegas like the Boston
started booking rooms first week Frank
Santorini Santorini the soprano showed
up with the sunglasses bull bounce to
check on him and it's been all downhill
ever since before you know if any
February don't be doing open mics and
[__] the massachusett cuz he got
bounced out of Boston that's why I was
in Vegas he was teaching classes too
MECs right and he collected all the
[__] money the money that he came out
here yeah I left with the money without
teaching the class oh the story about
the benefit yeah I heard that one Debbie
[__] the waitress had the benefit this
is all allegedly no this is the people
who told me were right huh hey remember
this is club 56 the owner was the old
Jew used to be called chick land up on
never Route 93 north what next - what's
with where's Wes [__] Jay Leno from I
don't know this was the town that Nancy
Kerrigan was from and over and over
right hand over man yeah that's Jay
Leno's how is he and it was grilled 93
what was it cause the restaurant
checkland before chickaletta from 99 to
2000 - it became he did a great job of
ten booking comic John Tobin no no I was
this Jewish guy oh yeah and there was
Dick Darley there was this club 56 and
then there was that that plays downtown
the famous place on Monday it's comedy
stop no the big comedy connection yes of
the Mondays I would go down there and
the really cool guy would host the Irish
guy where I got rest and soul he's dead
he was good Kevin Knox Kevin yeah that
was my route yeah I was a feature act
dude and I would Thursday's a kid up
there would get me like a gig in the
neighborhood and then Fridays and
Saturdays I would do 56 Sundays they get
me something in New Hampshire by the
airport or something yeah
and then one day I would stay and go to
the comedy film yeah and the guy with
the gammon problem Penny Favorita no the
other guy with again the manager they
have a gambling problem
Billy Downs whoever managed ball Barkley
yes well managed that place had a
gambling problem
yeah the guy who got me into Boston was
the guy that was an attorney that came
out all the Angela Paul the Angela was
the one who made the call for me
who's the gay guy from Boston really
good-looking was out here for a while
good friends of Chrismukkah why--i
sweetheart sweetheart
Kimmy love letter Jimmy love letter yeah
they were all regulars at the school
yeah right what's the other guy used to
dressed up like Dracula Oh Dom fig
Dominic fig yeah he still he only comes
out on Halloween then yeah yeah you got
a fate you got a facebook let me tell
you about the the aku-aku and Wooster I
remember I used to play with Billy Berg
Billy used to back when he was Billy
he used to open for me little squeaky
voice Billy Barry was [__] sweet he
wasn't as aggressive as he is now he was
just he was just a sweet kid would use
this 93 94 maybe and I Drive out with
him one week and I go up there's a place
called cheapies donuts across the street
from the aku-aku and I just remember I
remember the name because I thought when
you're when you're shopping for donuts
is cost is that is that big on your list
that they're cheap donuts you just buy
some [__] so I buy a dozen donuts
because I know how bad late show Friday
is right so I figure I'll give out some
treats
I'll keep keep him [__] focused so I
go up there and I go up and and I do
this bit I said this bit where was I
would read a deadbeat Father's Day card
written to a deadbeat dad so I'm reading
the card and some guy in the back stands
up and he goes hey I'm a deadbeat dad
and I don't appreciate that and so a guy
in front of them turns around he goes
shut up and sit down [__] now two
parties of Wooster guys [__] hair
slicked back they still got their
varsity jackets on even though they're
in their 40s they're drinking those
[__] scorpion bowls and they
collapsed on each other like a rugby
match and [__] tables are flying people
are throwing [__] plates they call
they call the police
and I stay on stage I'm calling it like
a fight he hits him on the left oh he's
down watch out for the scorpion ball oh
he's got your back brother don't worry
about it
Smitty's here and they keep fighting the
fight went on so [__] long that the
police showed up on the
I was still it was like a seven minute
fight just rolling around the room and
they had those ila phone doors they
broke through the xylophone door and
then they start dragging guys out the
doors didn't help
and it ended uh note so then they all
[__] leave and now the crowd is in
disarray and people's drinks are knocked
over and I just start handing out Donuts
I'm like it's gonna be alright everybody
we're gonna face I got 20 minutes left
we're gonna finish this [__] up and then
like you said before chick in the front
row throws up on the stage Margot what
do you think everybody threw up there
everybody threw up the guy 83 throw-ups
yeah the Chinese Way there's they're
like used to it now I was gonna add that
did they card back then it was that like
high school kids it was a mix of
underage kids and you know Worcester is
like a dilapidated like defunct factory
town all those factories are out of
business and a lot of people aren't
welfare it's it's it's taken a tick up
lately they're coming back but it was a
sad [__] place just big brick
factories with no [__] smoke coming
are those smokestacks they're cold cold
factories with sad people I gotta be
honest with you for a guy like me and
you're gonna be in chocolate at the time
being a regular at The Comedy Store and
being able to perform on Boston I
thought I was a movie star yeah once I
had accomplished those two things even
if it was an open mic at the comedy
connection and actually that was one of
my all-time favorite yeah that was a
[__] to the table Fanueil Hall right
yeah that was that was you could rock
that I still remember going there for
the weekend what broke and just being in
heaven just either downstairs yeah going
across the street to the hotel we did
that two day stint where all we did was
me him ally and and that's what you know
I mean job blessing we were broke
yeah Joe would pay for everything we're
even lobster claws
that's the fact the money we would never
dance
Jack that he was taking care of all of
us with that fear [__] money and it
was just and there was a lot of coke
floating around in those days I both
nights I disappeared at once Jo got off
the show the second he goes Diaz [__]
left again have a call forward I would
have a ban yeah I paid to be blowing up
I just turn it off
I could go bother in the room I'd get
back my hotel would make me change rooms
so Rogan would think I was into away
that make him change me room cuz I don't
want nobody not gonna make go I would
disappear dude they used to pay people
in coke they give you $100 packet a coke
after you set that one and guys would do
it at the bar there was not making this
up and there's a film about it it's
called when stand-up stood out and it's
about Boston back in the 80s where was
it where is that because I saw it so
it's on YouTube I think I think you
watch on YouTube yeah this guy France
Alameda made it yes and it's about how
much coke was opens days and that the
comics actually staged a protest because
the club owner told them at the the old
comedy connection which was unwarranted
Street told him they couldn't do lines
at the bar while the show was going on
but they wanted to watch the other
comments cuz they were all they were all
doing new [__] every night [__]
around and they want to see each other
and do blow and they they told me they
couldn't and so they picketed they
refused to do the club and I had to give
in a guard fine you guys can do coke at
the bar I'm not sure if that's in the
movie but it's about that time now now
while you're up there with Rogan Dane
Cook's already at the comedy connection
he was an impromptu he did stand up in
front of an intro probably to a pirate
yeah they were called they were called
kind of Kent room in the name but it was
Bobby Kelly and and Dane and I think one
other kid might have been two other kids
but it was definitely definitely Bobby
and Dane something the monkeys Alan the
monkeys who was called
and they used to go up and they were
silly because like the thing about
Boston is you really could do
because it was a closed community so
there wasn't a lot of people that came
to town like you're a rarity not many
people were brought in mm oh wow very
rare I had a bag bag yeah he paid me
break even money yeah because I'm loaded
with fees that's right I need you for
yeah Sonia so you're in a world where
you have to be different than the other
hundred comics in town if you had the
same voice as somebody else they'd come
down on you it was not it was not
acceptable so it forced people to
develop their own thing and so Alan the
Monkees was like the only sketch group
I'd ever seen in Boston nobody else did
it and and so uh and then they branched
out and started doing their own thing
but I think they felt they felt hacky
but I thought they were funny you know
they were goofballs just a great you
know looking back like that was just a
great scene of yeah you Dane Cook
Janeane bill burr Patrice O'Neal
Teresa's in Boston - Louie CK up Louie
CK Marc Maron a man was already a
veteran well married Maron Dave cross
Louie they all started about two years
ahead of me and Rogan and then me and
Rogen's class was like spilly was a
couple years after us Bobby Kelly was a
couple years after us Patrice was a few
years after us and then yeah and then
there were guys like I said so many guys
that went out to be big writers Brian
Kylie I think is the best writer I've
ever met has been writing monologue
jokes for Conan since day one every
[__] day for 25 years that dude shows
up sharpens his pencil and writes 50
[__] monologue jokes and he's a
machine and he got to read his Twitter
feed Brian Kylie Kile why check out his
Twitter feed [__] golden jokes every
day and he came out of that like I said
Jonathan Groff came out of that and then
you got you know guys it never left but
that are some of the comics I consider
the best comics I've ever seen
Don Gavin Steve Sweeney Lenny Klaw
mark you mentioned before Tony V Mike
Donovan guys that [__] destroy that
our craftsman that it beautiful jokes
timing and they have personas that are
unlike anybody you've ever seen before
so crowds in Boston are always good to
this day it's my best market I go back I
sell out all my shows rocking crowds
it's it's still an amazing place to do
stand-up I'm interested to see what you
think happened because I'm from there
and I remember early high school they
still had the comedy connection on top
of Fame hall but then that closed and
through college there wasn't literally
nothing like yeah I left before left
Boston opened so I get it seemed like
there was like a 10 years or something
where there's literally not a comedy
club yeah there was a guy that came in
and am I gonna say his name but he had
one of the bigger clubs and he started
running the other clubs out of business
on purpose he was buying up a lot of
advertising in the local paper telling
comics if they work to the other place
they couldn't work his place bringing it
out of town headliners changed the whole
table reset the table changed the scene
and started paying the opening acts of
future acts no money at all and so a lot
of good comics left town because of that
or just stopped doing it it was bad it
was bad for the city but now the city's
had a resurgence guy named John Tobin
who runs laughs Boston his [__] great
dude great nose comedy and he goes back
to that club you were talking about dude
grill 93 the the what was it called the
club we were talking about before we're
going yeah yeah he was he started out as
a door guy there then he became the
manager then he started booking clubs
downtown and now he's got rooms all over
the place he's got a room of Worcester
he's got one in Springfield he's got one
and I think Cape Cod and he's open them
all over the place and this guy's really
[__] sharp and so there's this been a
real good bounce-back well you have been
interesting like I loved my open mic
story like I loved it yeah looking back
on it I really enjoyed myself like I had
in Denver remember I got on stage when
Roseanne
to clean and she had just left them her
baby for years so yeah Rose Denver was
hot
Roseann left heat you know people were
looking at Denver you had Steve McGrew
yeah what the time you know he just
missed the boat he was just too late for
the boat on so many different levels but
he had three different hours your cord
Steve McGrew oh yeah and one week
yesterday yeah yeah right away what the
[__] yeah you know so it was Todd Jordan
returns and they had this big thing
going you got the comedy works you know
once I got banned from the comedy room
was watched my hands on the Seattle
that's why I hooked up with Josh wolf
from Brody Stephens and that was a scene
that it made me who I am today
I could calmly underground with a
phenomenal Club right and it's so when
you look back and you see that Josh wolf
is still in the business and you know
Brody was a stubborn in the business I
mean you look at the percentages I mean
with you you know Patrice O'Neal God
rest his soul but is Patrice berm Dane
Robert Kelly Rogan Janeane still doing
something yeah David Cross he they
always throw him the [__] show it's
gonna get canceled right
you know Marin yeah solid Louis solid
you know and you solid and the
generation before us you had [__]
Steven right you had us you had a Jay
Leno Paula Poundstone Kevin Meany Lenny
Clarke Lenny Clarke Lenny Clarke was
dice pushed me on stage Lenny Clarke
talked me and I had class like I saw
that picture of him Rogan and his
brother yeah and I still remember I used
to shop with fashion block well that was
a car sales they had you know suits and
then they had off the rack
I bought off the rack I became friends
the guy the guys name was Bob Schultz
great guy Jewish guy from Brooklyn
always had a Jew story always had a
great race is [__]
black joke I don't be afraid of them
when the blacks went to war with the
Jews and the Bronx huh and like 93 and
I'll never forget going into fashion bar
and they were white people all over he's
like thank God were beating up those
[__] whatever they call black people
he was just yelling it and bald
yeah it was there was what [__]
[__] him up and like I don't know
some pilot Bushwick somewhere in
Brooklyn yeah blacks got into it with
Jews and he was talking about blame
wouldn't make a long story oh I know
what it was it was when that binds you
to he got he got chased through the
streets he I card died and then there
was like race Wars and right it was out
by Coney Island what's that area
whatever well yeah yeah yeah it was 91
92 then when I saw him go up I took a
liking to ya I always bought off the
rack there when I saw Lenny Clarke and
his Rodney Dangerfield special I had
just gotten separated we just talked
about this the other day and I didn't
give a [__] I wanted and I went Bob take
the card today we're going over to the
real suits and I bought like four
[__] suits at the time 1987 let's say
there was six hundred apiece
and I started wearing suits because of
Lenny but I started bombing even more
yeah like I was on the bombing streak
and it's like I'm doing comedy three
years I see Lenny inspires me they taken
a different way now I'm doing the
combination of dice wedding and Kennison
and I'm sprinkling the wool Hicks in
there right and I still got the prior
element going but I pushed the Lenny as
much as I could with this suit but the
percentage of bombings I had a notebook
in those days and I remember every time
I wore suits just Bob yeah Bob Bob are
you logged how you did each time you
know laughter okay I had to have you
know anything about me I'm captain
[__] records yeah everything gets
logged in how much I got paid who also
went on stage how the joke I did tried
oh I would write [__] you you suck quit
[__] criminal you're never gonna mount
anything yeah I mean I would just Torme
that boys wow you still have all those
notebooks yeah yeah and I would love to
write the kind of missing missing 97
through 99 that's why my car got code
cannon it took like three years of
notebooks yeah those are really
interesting cuz those are my first two
years I know what I was feeling like I
would I would be brutally honest
would you write down if you'd done coke
that night or anything you could see it
and write it yeah yeah when he's logging
in at 4:30 in the morning to see the ink
[__] no no there was no computer
everything was done by him
yeah all these notebooks were October
8th Comedy Store same trip Alicia eye
and then I would put 15 minutes I tried
a new joke but I bombed with oh I expect
how much work do I put into this I suck
10 o'clock show did a lot better I
redeemed myself it's time you put a
little more effort into this I got paid
15 bucks Sam Tripoli
Kevin Fitzgerald and at least I had were
on the show
I just just cover my ass yeah somebody
once told me just just what happened
just as a lock and then at the end of
the month I would take the page and go I
did 22 sets my goal for next month is 27
sets I did 26 sets I bombed 21 times I
did okay 23 times I did excellent three
times if I don't pick this number up by
this date I should just shoot myself how
is that again well they say success
comes from writing down your goals
that's the thing I read I remember
everything all the time you read that
write down when I walk in the door at 10
o'clock at night whether my wife is up
the baby that's fine
I'm 56 and I still have the same habit I
had 10 years ago even without the coke
I'm
doing the same thing as I did at night
when I walk in from doing this set that
I did would only accept the coat so I
walk in I pee I washed my hands I get
the Comedy Store off of me I you know
whatever I get a beer and get not a beer
but I get like a water I'll do a few
bong hits and then I open up that
notebook that's the first thing I know
there's nothing else you have to do ya
go little notebook go to the set list
you had that you were gonna do that new
joke you were gonna try I didn't try so
now you have something to complain about
yeah so tonight I'll write October 8th
Sam sir please show
all right well he paid me and how I did
the original will show how do you see
this that's gonna be different some of
the write what I did differently and
once I do that then I go to the journal
side of the notebook and I close out my
day how was my day today in the desert
did this I spent time with my family you
know I'm saying yeah I always keep that
dial right that's great you know at this
point right now the performance is there
you know I could still bat 3:27 any
given night I just need to write you
know I don't have to perform as much as
I had to 10 years ago I could just write
and get the same result but this is a
word for me now when I was when you know
when you first got into it I didn't
watch TV for the first ten years of
comedy I don't even know what the TV was
I watch some TV in the daytime yeah I
know I remember never seeing Seinfeld
and everybody was talking about I never
watch run and watch TV that's right
friend
yeah never saw an episode of friends if
you were real common you don't know
anything yeah what's on TV if you're
real yeah you have no idea and you
missed your cousin's wedding and you
missed your buddy's 30th birthday party
you don't know me Kate you didn't do
that it's really weird when you try to
still try to be normal during an open
mic because you can't yeah because you
have to force your principles to think
that way mm-hmm like everything is I
know like what are you doing Saturday
November 14th
your uncle's are getting together good
son
dumb little [__] yeah right I'm not
going and there's anything is is it
wasn't even a discipline it was just in
my mind going to Long Island to my
cousin's wedding just never felt like no
but I'm getting spots to stand up New
York they're giving me [__] three
spots on a Saturday night I used to I
used to drive from New York from Boston
I would finish my sets on a Saturday
night at the aku-aku in Worcester Late
Show get to get off stage at at midnight
I get in the car and I would drive three
and a half hours I would get to New York
at 3:30 in the morning I crash on
friends couches they were always a
hassle call and friends hey can I stay
at your place gonna stay at your place
wearing out the [__] welcome mat at
all your friends places having nights
where you couldn't find a place to stay
and so you go down and you get a hotel
that you can't afford and you stay there
also you can hang out of the club and
maybe get a spot at 1:30 in the morning
I did that for two years and when I
finally broke in and I moved to New York
and I was getting three four or five
sets a night hundred bucks a spot and I
get invited to a cousin's wedding in
Long Island not even a thought not even
an option
I'm so [__] excited to do those shows
it's everything it's sexual it's
physical its mental its creative it's
this inflow of energy and acceptance
from the crowd that you've never had
before and you're doing it in the most
romantic city in the world you're in
[__] New York City on the pavement
hailing cabs to get across town and run
in do a set get out grab a bagel and a
light and sweet coffee from a deli go
down to the village walk past [__]
homeless people and street musicians so
you can duck into the basement of a club
pull out your piece of paper before you
go on do your new [__] at the end of the
night you got [__] 600 bucks cash in
your pocket and you're at a friend's
couch knocking at the door at [__]
2:00 in the morning hey guys hey how was
your night it was great I [__] did
six shows I want to hear every detail
they think it's the most fascinating
thing that or sit at a table with a
friend of the
and make small talk oh come on this goes
back to yeah that I was in the main room
I said I have to be honest with you
people
you know it's like people who don't have
kids who really don't understand do you
have a kid you know then you get it I
just don't look around for you telling
me I can't meet you tonight I have to
stay on with the kids and be like what
are you talking about you're wealthy may
[__] your kids
I regret that so much though yeah
because I'm so the opposite let me tell
you son I'm telling you we are the
people in the [__] podcast Ville in
reality well I was do you really think I
gave a [__] boy we're all at fifty-six
with a child I really don't give a [__]
I can't really don't give a [__] it's so
weird and that's why we started this
conversation off with the you know why
don't I want to have a go to the Friars
Club security he said I don't belong
there
like I look like whenever I see like
pictures of the old comedians what's
that [__] guy's name that was an
analyze that that played the gangster
he's an old-time time is also an casino
he tells the old guy if he Bobby Slayton
no [__] the Bobby Slade wasn't casino
was he no he was the old guy that told
Alan King oh yeah yeah right Alan King
always hangs out the fryers he looks
like a fryers he was the Dean right he
looked like yeah every time I see him
he's got like that I don't know it just
has and I'm not insulting you anyway
Greg this is how I feel it just it just
wouldn't be a place to like finish right
I don't know why but I know that going
in
it's like this weed cafe yeah I don't
but Alan King when my dad died after
being a member of the
Friars Club for [__] 30 years that
place wept for him Alan King did the
memorial for my dad he hosted it he got
up and he cried talking about my dad was
beautiful and all so what did you dad do
he was a radio guy no [__] I was Boston
no New York he's a Bronx guy spent his
entire life living in New York and he
didn't listen listen to me yeah I'm sure
you did
he was he was Sinatra he played Sinatra
Tony Bennett victim own [__] Aretha
Franklin what station was it wew
oh please yeah yeah and wew played rock
well there was FM and AM he was on AM
okay
the FM FM side was what was the girl's
name oh she's still around meg Meg
Griffin
she had like that oh boy Allyson steel
good night the night burn Alison steel
she was best friends with
what's-her-name from Jefferson Airplane
Grace Slick that was her best friend the
two of them were [__] the rock and
roll Kings in New York Queens in New
York and she would she would do that
that's the night out Alison steel you
know like I heard it almost like the
only place like people always ask stupid
questions on Facebook like what
celebrities you want to get high with
none of you no no no wait who do you
want to get but I wish I could have a
conversation like Jackie Gleason mm-hmm
you know like that that's in a regular
bar yeah I don't need to belong to some
[__] organization that long times I
am I can do those guys I just yeah dad
took my daughter swimming right here in
NoHo so we have a Saturday class with
daughter and before I got there my wife
because you know there's no parking I
think we mean there's no park I pulled
in and there was a park where I parked
right in is I'm getting out of the car
some little Mexican's excuse me excuse
me you know me I played that I don't
stop for no yeah just keep walking I
know I gave up yeah they just let me
park just keep walking like you own the
joint
excuse me excuse me I walked into the
why I don't think his ice paperwork is
up-to-date so he couldn't go into the
wine with me yeah he's not gonna dig in
no he couldn't dig in so please uh so uh
that's what's that have to do I sit down
and my wife gloss is not waiting on my
wife is like the queen of panic there's
no parking anyway Sam parked right there
yeah she just wasn't that way a girl
gets a [__] about the valet why are you
[__] buy into this [__] my guy behind
who knows oh yeah cuz it's next to the
Masons oh so she goes the guy goes to
get Lou without he's having a meeting so
they rent the lab boat parking lot so
you know what those people over they
could suck my dick one-night-only a
stone to the gills with our friend one
of these great friends gay guy who was
alive oh the one you met with boys ahoy
oh yeah right right Eric yeah okay so we
drive down 7-eleven Street whatever that
that Kalinga what is going on them we'll
call the pizza we want to do something
we're coming from the ice I so we're
driving and they're all out there and
there's a bunch of torches and they're
standing out in the front like saluting
each other whenever the Nazi thing is
son I beat though I got the best part is
he turned around and did it again
I love the French souffle I almost
crashed the car so much and being in the
car my best friend Roger okay and he had
a Chrysler New Yorker 1982 brand-new
cruise in the afternoon and he was the
king of beeping and saying [__] the
people at the bus stop huh yeah yeah no
hablo next time get immigration they
take off yeah he just say things to
people
ya know three two one day we were
driving a car stops like a car in front
he stops and never be like doing like
eight every was doing 60 now you're
doing it's because a family was leaving
and they were getting in a car and
another family was waving to them like
they're like okay yeah good luck don't
forget Roger bull of the family is an
agent of chaos oh my god I love seeing
people walk lillte yeah I see you walk
on thank assuming right we had that how
BP and say something yes the best is
when he getting me high and then he's on
the on the highway be better people
what the highway this is steroids 134
yeah there's not a lot of smart people
now for now if you had it that way
you're pretty stupid [__] yeah one way I
loved it was like you fail to get on the
101 of the 405 405 is like yeah no one
there to hit people that's why they're
in traffic yeah they got time to burn if
you're in the 134 you're in [__] bill
you can want to buy USC take out of
painting kids to get into the school
Lynn Swann retired all of a sudden cuz
that's just gonna go down there's no
bigger [__] pay over school in USC oh
yeah I'll tell ya not you sir we all
look at but the legacy you know if your
parent went all of a sudden you get in
automatically what the [__] is that all
about how how do I get knocked out I
worked my ass off in high school I
joined the [__] Model UN Club and I
went to [__] Tokyo to debate global
warming with a bunch of kids from around
the world you really know you're saying
like if I'm that kid look I wasted my
[__] weekend so I could go and
pretend I'm in the UN so I get credit
towards college get [__] straight A's
not even a anymore you got to get a 4.3
there's no more 4.0 now it's like
because we need take an AP class you get
extra points and my kid I'm doing it you
gotta do the joke I'm doing on stage
about it okay okay I do a joke you won't
so my kid just my kid just got into
college and you know I was actually kind
of surprised because he's not not that
bright of a kid he had all DS and C's
really low SAT scores so we have to hire
one of those fancy Hollywood college
placement centers $175,000 but he got in
the USA he's on the rowing team which is
exciting because he's never rowed before
and we just told him his Indian name is
him row slow it never works but I
[__] love it I think you've had me
there for me you did pay an enrichment
center $175,000 I listen you come to me
with that scam
I'm dropping my daughter rouse you get
the job because 175 to get you in that
car yeah it's not worth the [__] it's
really out now there was just article we
actually hired this this woman she works
a lot of kids at my kid went to Santa
Monica High School big big public high
school very diverse and so they actually
look for kids from that school because
they want actually want diversity of
states and they want specifically kids
that can handle like that kind of
community so we hired this woman to cost
two grand and she went out and she knows
every [__] school in the country she
knows which ones have good professors
good programs the ones is right they
they give your kid an assessment task
figure out what his strengths are help
them find a major locate schools that
that are that are a good value for the
money and that are giving money to kids
just because they're from certain types
of schools so we worked with her for six
months she gave us a list of schools
flew him out me and him would take these
[__] weekends Boston one weekend
Chicago one weekend New York one weekend
Philly one weekend having a blast
he's got fake ID I'm taking him to bars
could we'd go to whatever the college
bar was for that college because I said
I want you to see what its gonna be your
night life's gonna be like so we go in
me and him at a college bar [__] 53
year old ball guy standing around while
kids are doing jello shots and my son is
just taking it all in talking with some
girls feeling it out that's what we did
every [__] weekend for like for like
a month it was great and so we found
this school in Chicago let's go to
DePaul University biggest Catholic
school in the country DePaul the fall
yeah right basketball club yeah they won
the day they were in the finals the NCAA
is one year Division one school right
that's what they're called that's right
yeah
so he's got this school and they gave a
[__] chunk of money and it's not an
expensive school but it's a great school
and he's loving life he's [__] living
it up he's up there he's got his
roommates or it's got three roommates
they're all African American half the
floors gay
he's on a gay floor for whatever reason
I put him on that
and he's hanging out with these gay kids
every night til three o'clock in the
morning they watch and [__] movie
marathons are playing board games and
then you know he goes out to Boys Town
which is the gay area Chicago I go
what'd you do last night he goes yeah I
was out to it I was out in Boys Town
till 4:00 in the way I go are you gonna
dance on the dark side son he's like I
don't know dad oh yeah I don't know so
he's gonna he's getting a good education
he's living it up you know you have a
daughter also
yes she's 16 okay so now you have to go
through this [__] yeah you're right
right so welcome to all over again
yep yeah this is what it's all about
yeah the final stages and I really
applaud you because you've pulled it off
while doing your craft a lot of people
say [__] I'm just gonna raise my
family not do this [__] hmm you played
the card the right way and I commend you
for it thanks man
you looked around you saw kids forgotten
comics years ago and how [__] up they
are you know when you talk to comics
kids oh they tell you there's something
missing there hmm and I didn't want that
for my daughter and all either I told
her yesterday in the car
little problem yesterday I could be
anywhere I can be in a Dodger game
whether I could be on the road making
money but I worked my schedule the way I
do is spend time with you you know we
lose money guys like you and I yeah play
some leaves off it
we need your Tober 31st nope never work
on Halloween is canceling nope I'm doing
the David Spade show on the 30th though
so nice 130f yeah yeah I'm back a little
by 4:30 right popping Joe's pizza yeah
they sure Hollywood so that should I
don't mind but I'm not going that no
Halloween Halloween Valentine's Day
Christmas Thanksgiving Easter school
concerts what
Mother's Day Mother's Day probably got
that I look at the year before I put
them all on dates and I ship them to the
age and I got all booked up that day say
no office don't even worry about but
they want you know that they won't tell
them it's gonna have to be a different
day Mother's Day yes Father's Day I
chose this way I could go on the road
every [__] weekend like them but I
gotta have them but you know what
I'd much rather I heard know who the
[__] I am
yeah yeah you're a good dad you spent a
lot of quality time with her hey listen
I'm gonna leave here now go run some
errands I'm back here doing a podcast
science podcast for that you're doing a
wackadoo a science podcast with him my
daughter
no yeah we hadn't put him up because
it's [__] bad but it's just her
talking about science on the microphone
yeah I put the earphones on no [__] I
make believe she's on CBS that's funny
yes PA that's gravel the she now says oh
my god go back to meet her and her
mother watch it on the phone I'm gonna
download it and we oh my god so you
think kids watched again I'm gonna use
two million Wow she's so [__] NBC
she's like well when do I start doing
the reads for stamps.com
I started really yeah that's good church
oh what's happened now you gotta give
ten to your mother for the bank account
and you keep that I love it
that's it when you want to see a toy you
want you don't need us you spend you at
your own $10 okay which you know it's
like I'm wonder cutting uh tremendously
but you can't give everything but you
got to teach you the value without what
she's 18 you should you should post us
oh yeah yeah she'll post him way before
that my wife downloads them yeah they're
in the cloud there a mister in that I
mean that's you know for years I was
under the illusion that it was about
money that's what we spoke about him won
that money at everything
oh if you have a child I don't forget
when I had my first child the door that
doesn't talk to me for her third
birthday guess what this
[__] idiot all right guess what I
bought for our third birthday party and
then righted a bunch of white kids to
her party
what $150 Paia hands love you
Yeah right really good party three of
the parents hate it everybody was
looking for fish pizza from dominos all
right a little chicken [__] you don't
even know if it's a rat or a mouse yeah
yeah how was it shocked because I was my
mom would have these huge birthday
parties for me you know with a bandana
pinata and 200 people and I thought it
was all they want to do is just your
time mm-hmm that's all they want they
don't know anything about money I think
of the mint cheese whatever they get
yogurt Oh expensive date with it last
night after karate we were - yum yum
donuts I get the bran muffin cuz I'm an
old man I got a [__] blood yeah she gets
the blue doughnut with sprinkles and we
wants to send the street and then I
gotta [__] give her a kiss tell her
good night I'm going down the store to
rip into some [__] [__] like a
cabbage it's like being in the Mafia he
didn't wonder she prays yeah and she
doesn't know in two hours I'm gonna be
at the store told him I leave my wife's
[__] and how I don't get [__] the
flu because I eat my wife says oh that's
my [__] life walk into my [__] the
world
you got any dates coming up oh yeah you
kidding me oh he's gone into the [__]
that notebook he's working the [__]
roll and you wanna if you want to check
them out you go to Fitz dog.com for
tickets I'm working oh my favorite club
in the country San Francisco punchline
almost went out of business but they're
back November 8th through the fair and
I'm sorry the 7th through the 9th then
I'm gonna be going out to the Casey
improv November 15 through 17 then I'll
be at the Denver Comedy Works downtown
November 21 through 23 then I'm gonna be
hitting the yeah just give me two or
three days since an hour
we did this sitting there with a feather
Philly Cincinnati it's all outfits dog
calm man you
have you scheduled yeah the fallen hey
well I don't work in the summer that's
right summer I got the kids they were
out of school I got you know clubs where
people don't show up because they'd
rather be at the [__] beach and you
walk in there in the rooms 3/4 full and
they look so you like yeah right well
it's rodeo week I don't see this Uriah
Heep is playing at the State Fair now
now I'm at movie night with my kids
we're gonna Beach taking a little
weekend trips I'm upset that I gotta
leave this weekend without real I'm
going to Kansas City on Friday to the
Uptown Theater and Saturday night I will
be at the Paramount Theatre in Denver we
out of the second show 9:30 we a few
tickets left there a few tickets left in
Kansas City
I'm excited to meet some green chili on
Saturday oh yeah that's when I go to
Colorado for [__] Joey
where do I get it Sam's done before
what's number it's right next to the
club Sam's number three years number
three next to the Denver Comedy Works
yeah no [__] really good with two
tortillas hi open for breakfast today I
know before breakfast you can create a
little two eggs bacon with potatoes with
toast you [__] said I want toast give
me a bold green chilly - and you have
that little green chili for breakfast
you dick those nice and hard spicy it's
good with the Bausman with that oh you
take a [__] smoke comes out of it you
know I'm saying there's a little smoke
looks like grandpa's basement
[__] it don't forget the church is
brought to you by my bookie listen
football season is upon us you like
winning money you're like betting sports
I'll tell you where I put my money down
my book bead on AG if you're trying to
bet the NFL baseball UFC MMA street
hockey whatever the [__] they got better
the sentence and more lines than any
other sports book period this year
they're running a super contest a
hundred miles to enter you picked five
teams against the spread you rack up the
points first place is guaranteed
$100,000 back rub [__] damn and it's a
holiday
they just revamped their site and it's
looking tremendous so go take a look if
you haven't I know this Major League
action tonight I know this [__]
football this tomorrow I know this
football on Saturday let's do this [__]
double your first deposit now use promo
code Church they're 100 percent bonus on
your initial deposit of up to $1,000
nobody takes care of you like your uncle
Joey
visit my bookie dot AG today right now
that's my bookie dot AG and don't forget
to use the promo code Church when
creating your account to claim your
bonus and don't forget Thursday morning
check my Instagram account man flavors
world I'm gonna be dropping a video for
you [__] I don't have pics this
week what I have is advice on how to
make penis and use my bookie to make
[__] gay this the church is also
brought to you by for him calm listen
with age comes wisdom but getting older
can also be a downer in that one
specific area 40% of men by the age of
40 struggle from not being able and to
maintain an erection why do guys turn to
weed solutions what it'll do nothing at
all when they can turn to medicine and
science expensive pills injections when
no man wants them nah listen be wise
checkout hymns that's four hymns calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men well known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you combat
erectile dysfunction
description solutions backed by science
and made more affordable by for hims
calm see results where other treatments
fall short and it's easy you answered
some questions about your medical
history you chat with a doctor it's a
confidential review and if you approve
products are shipped directly to your
door being being your best means
performing and your best listen it's
love season
nobody wants to show up with a gun with
no bullets it's a go-to for hems calm
try right now today and start off with a
free online visit go to forums dot-com
slash Church that's for hems calm slash
Church prescription products are subject
to dr. approval and require an online
consultation with a physician who will
determine if the prescription is
appropriate or not see website for full
details and safety information let me
tell you something this could cost you a
hundred houses if you went to a doctor
but I'm gonna save you money remember
that it's forums comm slash Church the
church is also brought to you one of my
personal favorites these guys are doing
an amazing job kettlebell kitchen
alright they started by two army vets
were also brothers their mission was to
change people's lives to making healthy
food more accessible eating healthy
today it's on everybody's mind what when
and where how much they eat will confuse
meal planning and breath time you know
you don't want to spend your entire
Sunday chopping carrots and roasts and
chicken breasts through it
that's what kettle bell kitchen comes in
they help you stay on your diet by
taking out the hassle of shopping and
cooking these meals come right to you
twice per week for optimal freshness
plus you'll never get bored because they
offer a personalized menu whatever works
for you
vegetarian keto all thirty pelayo
they got it you can even filter by your
calorie protein fat carbonate see you
got exactly the right foods for your
unique needs and all their meals a free
of dairy soy artificial sweeteners and i
made from ingredients that are usually
naturally gluten free unlike any other
meal boxes you can order one meal at a
time that's what I like or sign up for
the plan and you can change it up
anytime no long-term contracts they sent
me a sample of some Cuban pork roast
listen up [__] Cuban and it was
delicious so what are you waiting for
feed the champion inside of it with
kettle bell kitchen do me a favor grab a
pen
go to Kelly Bell kitchen calm right now
kettle bell ke TT le Bao bei Lao kitchen
put it together put it calm and there
you go enter coat church and I'm gonna
give you $25 off each of your first two
orders to new customers okay uncle
Joey's always showing up like the three
wise men I'm showing up with an envelope
that's 25 off your first two orders a
kettle bell kitchen bath top pressing
code Church
I want to thank kettle bell kitchen I
want to thank him for hims not time but
I want to thank my bookie don't forget
Instagram tomorrow my flavors world I'm
dropping a [__] video for you I want
to thank the original Irishmen [__] the
movie my brother mr. Greg Fitzsimmons
the real Irishmen this [__]
paints houses I want to thank a
[__]
happy whatever it is I know tomorrow's
another holiday Yom Kippur
yeah I'm Kippur happy New Year to you
and your family thank you I hope you
find the bag of pennies and [__] meet
you most importantly I want to thank you
guys for listening for supporting the
podcast you know I love you all my heart
don't forget uptown [__] feet
of Friday night eight o'clock the
Paramount Theater seven o'clock is sold
out 9:30 tickets are available right see
you Tuesday morning I love you stay
black have a great weekend Lee kick this
[__] mule